I would like to tell you about the most
embarrassing thing that it's ever
happened to me in my years of working as
a palliative care physician this
happened a couple of years ago I was
asked as a consultant to see a woman in
her 70s retired English professor who
had pancreatic cancer I was asked to see
her because she had pain nausea vomiting
when I went to see her we talked about
those symptoms and in the course of that
consultation she asked me whether I
thought that medical marijuana might
help her I thought back to everything
that I've learned in medical school
about medical marijuana which didn't
take very long because I had learned
absolutely nothing and so I told her
that as far as I knew medical marijuana
had no benefits whatsoever and she
smiled and nodded and reached into the
handbag next to the bed and pulled out a
stack of about a dozen randomized
control trials showing that medical
marijuana has benefits for symptoms like
nausea and pain and anxiety she handed
me those articles and said maybe you
should read these before offering an
opinion doctor so I did that night I
read all of those articles and found a
bunch more when I came to see her the
next morning I had to admit that it
looks like there is some evidence that
marijuana can offer medical benefits and
I suggested that if she really was
interested she should try it you know
what she said this 73 year old retired
English professor she said I did try it
about six months ago it was amazing I've
been using it every day since it's the
best drug I've discovered I don't know
why it took me seventy-three years to
discover the stuff it's
amazing that was the moment at which I
realized I needed to learn something
about medical marijuana because what I
was prepared for a medical school board
no relationship to reality so I started
reading more articles I started talking
to researchers I started talking to
doctors and most importantly I started
listening to patients ended up writing a
book based on those conversations and
that book really revolved around three
surprises surprises to me anyway one I
already alluded to but there really are
some benefits to medical marijuana those
benefits may not be as huge or as
stunning as some of the most avid
proponents of medical marijuana would
have us believe but they are real
surprise number two medical marijuana
does have some risks those risks may not
be as huge and as scary as some of the
opponents of medical marijuana would
have us believe but they are real risks
nonetheless but it is the third surprise
that was most surprising and that is
that a lot of the patients I talked with
whose turned to medical marijuana for
help
weren't turning to medical marijuana
because of its benefits or the balance
of risks and benefits or because they
thought it was a wonder drug but because
it gave them control over their illness
it let them manage their health in a way
that was productive and efficient and
effective and comfortable for them to
show you I mean let me tell you about
another patient Robin was in her early
40s when I met her she looked though
like she was in her late 60s she had
suffered from rheumatoid arthritis for
the last 20 years her hands were gnarled
by arthritis her spine was crooked she
had to rely on a wheelchair to get
around
she looked weak and frail and I guess
physically she probably was but
emotionally cognitively psychologically
she was among the toughest people I've
ever met in my sat down next to her in
the medical marijuana dispensary in
Northern California to ask her about why
she turns medical marijuana what it did
for her and how it helped her she
started out by telling me things that I
had heard from many patients before it
helped with her anxiety
it helped with her pain when her pain
was better she slept better and I'd
heard all that before but then she said
thing that I've never heard before and
that is that it gave her control over
her life and over her health she could
use it when she wanted in the way that
she wanted at the dose and frequency
that worked for her and if it didn't
work for her then she could make changes
everything was up to her most important
thing she said was she didn't need
anybody else's permission not a clinic
appointment not a doctor's prescription
not a pharmacist order it was all up to
her she was in control and if that seems
like a little thing for somebody with
chronic illness it's not not at all when
we face a chronic serious illness
whether it's rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus or cancer or diabetes or cirrhosis
we lose control and know what I said
when not if all of us at some point in
our lives will face a chronic serious
illness that causes us to lose control
we'll see our function to climb some of
us LC our cognition decline will be no
longer able to care for ourselves to do
the things that we want to do our bodies
will betray us and in that process we'll
lose control and that's scary just scary
that's frightening it's terrifying when
I talk to my patients my palliative care
patients many of whom are facing
illnesses that will end their lives they
have a lot to be frightened of pain
nausea vomiting constipation fatigue
their impending mortality but what
scares them more than anything else is
this possibility that at some point
tomorrow or a month from now they're
going to lose control of their health of
their lives of their healthcare and
they're going to become dependent on
others and that's terrifying so it's no
wonder really that patients like Robin
who I just told you about when that in
that clinic turned to medical marijuana
to try to claw back some semblance of
control how do they do it though how did
these medical marijuana dispensaries
like the one where I met
and how do they give patients like Robin
back the sort of control that they need
and how do they do it in a way that
mainstream medical hospitals and clinics
at least for Robin weren't able to
what's their secret so I decided to find
out I went to a seedy clinic in Venice
Beach in California and got a
recommendation that would allow me to be
a medical marijuana patient I got a
letter of recommendation that would let
me buy medical marijuana I got that
recommendation illegally because I'm not
a resident of California I should note
that I should also know for the record
that I never used that letter of
recommendation to make a purchase and
all of you DEA agents out there loved
the work that you're doing keep it up
even though it didn't let me make a
purchase though that letter was
priceless because it let me be a patient
it let me experience what patients like
Robin experienced when they go to a
medical marijuana dispensary and what I
experienced what they experienced every
day hundreds of thousands of people like
Robin was really amazing I walked in
with the clinic and from the moment that
I entered many of these clinics of
dispensaries I felt like that dispensary
that clinic was there for me there were
questions at the outset about who I am
what kind of work I do what my goals are
in looking for a medical marijuana
prescription or a product what my goals
are what my preferences are what my
hopes are how do I think how do I hope
this might help me what am I afraid of
these are the sorts of questions that
patients like Robin get asked all the
time these sorts of questions that make
me confident that the person I'm talking
with really has my best interests at
heart and wants to get to know me the
second thing I learned in those clinics
is the availability of education
education from the folks behind the
counter but also education from folks in
the waiting room people I met were more
happy as I was sitting next to them
people like Robin to tell me about who
they are why they use medical marijuana
what helps them how it helps them and to
give me advice and suggestions those
waiting rooms really are a hive of
interaction advice and support and third
the folks behind the counter I was
amazed at how willing those people were
to spend sometimes an hour or more
talking me through the nuances of this
strain versus that strain smoking versus
vaporizing edibles versus tinctures all
remember without me making any purchase
whatsoever think about the last time you
went to any hospital or clinic and the
last time anybody spent an hour
explaining those sorts of things to you
the fact that patients like Robin are
going to these clinics are going to
these dispensaries and getting that sort
of personalized attention and education
and service really should be a wake-up
call to the healthcare system people
like Robin are turning away from
mainstream medicine turning to medical
marijuana dispensaries because those
dispensaries are giving them what they
need if that's a wake-up call to the
medical establishment it's a wake-up
call that many of my colleagues are
either not hearing or not wanting to
hear when I talk to my colleagues
physicians in particular about medical
marijuana they say oh we need more
evidence we need more research in the
benefits we need more evidence about
risks and you know what they're right
they're absolutely right we do need much
more evidence about the benefits of
medical marijuana we also need to ask
the federal government to reschedule
marijuana to schedule 2 or 2 D schedule
it entirely to make that research
possible we also need more research into
Medical marijuana's risks medical
marijuana's risks we know a lot about
the risks of recreational use we know
next to nothing about the risks of
medical marijuana so we absolutely do
need research but to say that we need
research and not that we need to make
any changes now is to miss the point
entirely people like Robin aren't
seeking out medical marijuana because
they think it's a wonder drug
or because they think it's entirely
risk-free there seek it out because the
context in which it's delivered and
administered and used gives them the
sort of control they need over their
lives and that's a wake-up call we
really need to pay attention to the good
news though is that there are lessons we
can learn today from those medical
marijuana dispensaries and those are
lessons we really should learn these are
often small mom-and-pop operations run
by people with no medical training and
while it's embarrassing to think that
many of these clinics and dispensaries
are providing services and support and
meeting patients needs in ways that
billion-dollar healthcare systems aren't
we should be embarrassed by that but we
can also learn from that they're
probably three lessons at least that we
could learn from those small
dispensaries one we need to find ways to
give patients more control in small but
important ways how to interact with
healthcare providers when to interact
with healthcare providers how to use
medications in ways that work for them
in my own practice I've gotten much more
creative and flexible in supporting my
patients in using drugs safely to manage
their symptoms but the emphasis on
safely many of the drugs that I
prescribe are drugs like opioids or
benzodiazepines which can be dangerous
if overused but here's the point they
can be dangerous if they're overused but
they can also be ineffective if they're
not used in a way that's consistent with
what patients want and need so that
flexibility if it's delivered safely can
be extraordinarily valuable for patients
and their families that's number one
number two education huge opportunities
to learn from some of the tricks of
those medical marijuana dispensaries to
provide more education that doesn't
require a lot of physician time
necessarily or any physician time but
opportunities to learn about what
medications were using and why prognosis
trajectories of illness and most
importantly opportunities for patients
to learn from each other how can we
replicate what goes on in those clinic
and medical dispensary waiting rooms how
patients learn from each other how
people share from each
and last but not least putting patients
first the way those medical marijuana
dispensaries do making patients feel
legitimately like what they want what
they need is why as healthcare providers
we're here asking patients about their
hopes their fears their goals and
preferences as a palliative care
provider I ask all my patients what
they're hoping for and what they're
afraid of but here's the thing patients
shouldn't have to wait until they're
chronically seriously ill often near the
end of life they don't have to wait they
shouldn't have to wait until they're
seeing a physician like me before
somebody asks them what are you hoping
for what are you afraid of that should
be baked into the way that health care
is delivered
we can do this we really can medical
marijuana dispensaries and clinics all
across the country are figuring this out
they're figuring this out in ways that
larger more mainstream health systems
are years behind but we can learn from
them and we have to learn from them all
we have to do is swallow our pride put
aside the thought for a minute that
because we have lots of letters after
our name because we're experts because
we're chief medical officers of a large
healthcare system we know all there is
to know about how to meet patient's
needs
we need to swallow our pride we need to
go visit new medical marijuana
dispensaries we need to figure out what
they're doing we need to figure out why
so many patients like Robin are leaving
our mainstream medical clinics and going
to these medical marijuana dispensaries
instead we need to figure out what their
tricks are what their tools are and we
need to learn from them if we do and I
think we can and I absolutely think we
have to we can guarantee all of our
patients will have a much better
experience thank
[Applause]